[Music]  i have something to tell you  and you're very lucky because i've never  told anyone this in my whole life  you ready to make history  you say that every time  again it's a heck of a view oh it's more  than that maybe it's time we finally  tell somebody else  hey grandpa  i think you two should consider moving  out of the house that's what you're  worried about when your neighbors saw  you pushing nana around in the middle of  the night but i think they're hiding  some in that [ __ ]  there's a reason  we were the ones who found this  this is our riddle to solve  who are you  do you think he's some kind of alien he  could be dangerous  i think i know how to find him  take care of this  [Music]  i need to see where all this leaves  franklin and i want  you're always looking for an answer to  life's great mystery  i found mine  here in this house with  they you everything it's just the way to  protect the secret  there's more of those by the way a lot  more  [Music]  you